I want to talk about the latest
hysterical attempt by the anti Democrats
to overturn the referendum result first
they blamed races for it then a selfish
older generation then Murdoch then the
Daily Mail then the Russians now they're
screaming seventeen point four million
breaks the tears were duped into voting
leave because a few extra hundred
thousand quid was passed from one
campaign group to another so if that's
swung at for leave how come the nine
million pounds the government spent
sending leaflets to every household in
Britain didn't swing it for remain those
fighting to overturn Briggs didn't need
to believe it was the cheat a conspiracy
a brainwashing exercise because they
refused to see what it really was and
enraged scream by people who felt
abandoned ignores and patronized by our
political and liberal elite what these
supercilious self-serving remainders
needs to realize is the public's moved
on a recent poll showed a 57 percent
majority of us just want to get on with
getting out this week marks a year
before we exit the EU and go global the
anti Democrats need to get used to that
[Music]
who needs a satirist who needs satirist
when Carol parodies herself now so as
speaking is an hysterical anti-democrat
I open I think you're right I don't
think that the referendum result is
going to be unhinged by any technicality
but you still fail to address some
really key issues this that do remain
and I no pun intended
yes seventeen point four million people
voted to leave but they didn't know what
they were leaving for so let's throw it
forward let's throw it forward let's not
go back and fight the referendum again
let's just remember not find a note
random what we need to look at is we've
got a year from today until we leave the
EU yeah therefore we have got to make
sure that the deal that is in play
when Parliament gets to be have its vote
on the deal is good enough for the
country to benefit and prosper outside
the EU therefore I think Kirsten who is
the shadow brexit secretary is exactly
right
and instead of just enacting the results
for the referendum which we should
remember was advisory but the government
converted that into mandate reason the
wait wait wait did you say the hold on
Caroline let's just finish let me just
fit what I was talking about we can't we
don't we just want to finish my point no
I'm just going to my point which is this
when it comes to the deal let us assume
I don't think this is going to happen by
the way I think Parliament is going to
vote for the deal because they're going
to be whipped into submission but if if
Parliament votes against the deal then I
think that the following should happen
that the vote on whatever the deal is
should be turned to MPs not ministers
and MPs should be given a free vote on
the deal and let's take this latest
attempt to derail it is the load of
illness I just say so
I said you know my technicality on this
on this latest on I'm actually
interviewing this guy on my radio show
you see that chummy that's whistleblower
yeah yeah and one thing I know for a
fact that's a bit harsh she was actually
outed as being gay okay why did you take
part in the gay pride march if you
didn't want the Walther name we go when
it's sitting in Pakistan you're not
going to be watching the game party in
London no no I can guarantee you know I
think outing people is unethical right
and I don't think we should be
justifying it I think it had to be done
that's for his boyfriend to qualify why
dad I'm sweetheart very rarely can you
can you anyway let's not go I think
Majid carry on Rexie I don't think we're
gonna actually win if we try and say
it's actually a fickle to out people
without their permission I didn't say
the kalter and I said for this guy to
qualify why was I even though his
ex-boyfriends conversation oh no please
we do have a ground right
actually to calm things down can we go
to em there is absolutely nobody go to
poke opens a lot of ticks and hear from
the man in questions have you got the
sort of The Smoking Gun that says you
must spend the money in this way and we
are telling you to spend it now with
this group you have no no you don't know
we don't know it doesn't there's the
evidence is to do with coordination and
how every decision was run through
senior members how a IQ was based on the
vote leave office how I had never heard
of a IQ when the decision was made
absolutely no evidence
what were you say I was gonna make a
point about bricks actually and that is
that your introduction that this isn't
attempt to derail bricks it strikes me
as rather curious because then we just
saw on the screen there it still
believes in bricks it still wants breaks
it to happen he says if we take what he
says at face value and I don't see any
reason not to that's why guys could
actually say well I'm trying to say
right so he says he did it because he
believes in democracy in the rule of law
I believe him I don't think that this
derails the brexit result he himself
believes in brexit the electoral
commission has no powers to derail the
sovereign vote of this nation all this
is is an inquiry as there are many
inquiries into what happened during the
referendum including on the remain side
I agree the 90 million that was spent by
Cameron using taxpayers money should
have been looked into wasn't ethical as
well and so actually if it is about the
rule of law and democracy then that
investigation applies of both sides
almost full of me well bricks it staying
for legal purposes let's just see what a
solicitor for vote leave has to say to
the point you just made
imagine vote leave has twice been
cleared on this matter by the Electoral
Commission as has been the case
throughout vote leave is obligated to
review to the extent it cannot this long
elapsed period since a referendum all
such allegations and is doing so we will
as appropriate share any relevant
findings with the Electoral Commission
again as we have always done
briefly a Carol you've got me until you
almost saying whatever the deal we must
just go for of course of course we have
to respect and of course we must leave
and I think every sane politician agrees
that I'm a little concerned Majid I
respect your position or Sam socially I
think
I knew Rachel one of you saying that the
MPs should have a fridge or I didn't let
you do if your what you frightened of
I'm not frightened is because I sense
that there is a mood within many
quarters of Westminster that they do not
reflect what the British people have
voted for and it would be a fair
reflection but we must make sure it's
the right deal so you shouldn't be the
sort of foot World War 1 gang oh sorry
gung ho let's go let's go let's get the
measure deal but the idea of a free I
think I genuinely think would be very
very unfair to have to admit that this
was this was a deal that would probably
suited you British people that we're
getting the economy over a cliff you
tell me enough to talk about people
there you go well what happened the deal
that was that she put forward last week
that will remain in exactly the same
position for the next twenty-one months
isn't the deal that every hard break
Satya wants but we're prepared to do
that to make sure that we don't fall off
a cliff and to make sure that everything
is permanent and I think of course you
can thank you so as a supercilious
remainer
and hysterical I find this really
interesting because I think if this was
the other way round there's no way that
you would be saying what you're saying
if this was remained that had overspent
and if this was remained that hadn't let
me finish but what I'm saying is if we
had broken the rules which is what if
this is what the whistleblowers are
alleging evidence the runners have been
but the whistleblower is alleging that
if that was the case you would be saying
the elitist remain errs using their
money in it but you don't you you keep
on repeating this argument is yours
because I think the remain that the
remains unanswered also be looked at as
what I'd like to say it as a
parliamentary parliamentary secretary of
the Cabinet Office Chloe Smith
Conservative MP has said some has made
some rocks I think it's worthwhile
having a look at what she had to say in
Parliament the Electoral Commission
concluded that it was a well-run poll
and that it was delivered without
major issues now we also know that it
was one of the largest Democratic
exercises in our history
I recognize indeed we've seen it here
today that that referendum and it's
subject matter elicits high emotion so
yes its high emotion as we've just seen
I can assure you Colette me as a remain
I say to you I don't think that this is
about D rating the Bristol vote I'm not
trying to do it suppose I will assure
you that from my perspective and the
reason I'm keen to interview this
whistleblower is because actually it's
just about the rule of law I believe him
when he says he believes in brexit and
he's it more interested in democracy in
the world war one believe in democracy
if he's saying there's been there's been
messing about you can't just keep on
saying he believes in democracy when
he's trying to derail even the rule of
law there's no evidence for the cheating
going on we've got to stop this what he
was saying not a Gerald Kenny can you
not see that with Rachel's example there
you can love cricket and be upset if
there's bull tampering and still love
cricket
he loves brexit he wants bricks it to
happen but he wants it to happen fail
you know according to leave according to
his own words it was cheating and when
there's no evidence of that just as he
says in June doesn't mean it's not wrong
everything is an attempt to derail lots
of remaineth have to agree to disagree
on this one whatever